m
[Musique]
il n'est pas sûr que ce soit le vin de
cette vigne qui se consomme non loin de
là on lapin agile ou depuis toujours les
montmartrois viennent chanter des
chansons à boire
[Musique]
et
ans
et pas trop grand pour paulo et tous les
choristes
attention un deux trois
[Musique]
et maintenant le temps ici jean baptiste
prévost
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
le
[Applaudissements]
dans ce cadre qui n'a pas changé depuis
des lustres
une vielle aux accents criard évoque la
province comme les gravures accroché au
mur évoque le temps passer
[Musique]
le passé le présent voisine souvent ici
où l'on a plus que partout ailleurs le
culte des disparus
[Musique]